This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格লিশ。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着西装或盔甲？这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难抉择》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告是你伪造了两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测报告。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·兰吉尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWA percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
这就是在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听的TWA percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It's so great to have you here. Back for another episode. We've got another bonus episode for you today. These shorter episodes are a little
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，这是一档带你探讨我们二十多岁时经历的巨大变化、重要时刻和人生转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界何地。很高兴有你们陪伴。又迎来了新的一期节目。我们今天为你准备了另一期额外节目。这些较短的节目有点
bit different from our usual deep dives. Think of them as like little psychology snack breaks where we unpack a singular term, singular theory or psychological concept that might be misunderstood or just thrown around pretty casually online, terms that we might not be able to do like a full 50 minute episode on, but I still really want to cover. And today's topic, it actually is a big one for a mini episode. We're going to talk about perfectionism. You know what I realized the other day? I realized I have been doing this podcast for nearly.
不同于我们通常的深度探讨。把它们想象成心理学的小零食时间，我们在其中剖析一个单一的术语、单一的理论或心理学概念，这些概念可能被误解了，或者只是在网络上被相当随意地抛出，有些术语我们可能无法做成整整50分钟的单集节目，但我真的很想讲。而今天的话题，对于一期迷你节目来说，其实是一个很大的话题。我们要聊的是完美主义。你知道我前几天意识到什么吗？我意识到我做这个播客已经快
five years, I have never just done a standalone episode purely on perfectionism, which is ironic because it's probably the thing that I like struggle with more than anything else. You have no idea how many podcast episodes I have recorded that will never see the line of day because I didn't think they were good enough. It doesn't, probably more than that. And that's not even including the scripts. you know, how many ideas that I have that I've never acted on because I'm too afraid to start how many hours I spend thinking about how to be good at something and never actually doing
五年了，我从来没有做过一期纯粹关于完美主义的独立节目，这很讽刺，因为它可能是我比任何其他事情都更纠结的事情。你不知道我录制了多少集永远不会见天日的播客节目，因为我觉得它们不够好。这可能不止于此。这还不算那些剧本。你知道，我有多少从未付诸行动的想法，因为我太害怕开始了；我花了多少时间思考如何精通某事，却从未真正采取过
anything about it. I probably don't need to tell you it's an exhausting feeling. Perfectionism is an exhausting state of mind and I want to talk about it today. Broadly speaking, perfectionism is basically characterized by the need for excessively high standards. and the need for everything to be flawless. It's not a mental health condition, but it is kind of like a personality trait almost that a lot of us have. It is one of those traits that in all honesty, sounds kind of good at first.
任何行动。我可能不用告诉你，这是一种筋疲力尽的感觉。完美主义是一种令人筋疲力尽的心态，我今天想谈谈它。广义上讲，完美主义的基本特征是对过高标准的追求，以及要求一切都完美无缺。它不是一种心理健康问题，但它有点像一种我们许多人都有的人格特质。说实话，它最初听起来像是那种相当不错的特质之一。
When someone says, I'm a perfectionist, you know, we don't always think poorly of them. We think they're really good at things. They work really hard. They have high standards. They care deeply about what they do. I am sure so many people have been asked in job interviews, you know, what's your worst trait? And they've said perfectionist because they know it kind of makes them sound good.
当有人说“我是个完美主义者”时，你知道，我们并不总是对他们有不好的看法。我们觉得他们做事真的很擅长。他们工作非常努力。他们有很高的标准。他们深深地关切他们所做的事情。我确信很多人在求职面试中都被问过“你最大的缺点是什么”，而他们会说“完美主义”，因为他们知道这听起来能让他们显得很好。
And that's why people are so often applauded for it. They're applauded for these excessive high standards. Like it's a badge of honor. I will work harder than anyone because I am never able to prove I'm good enough to myself. Underneath perfectionism, it's not about. excellence, it's often about fear. It's about the underlying constant worry that you're going to fall short, that if you are not perfect, you are not enough. You have no value. Your life lacks meaning. People will never love you. It gets pretty psychologically heavy pretty quickly. So many of us live with
这就是为什么人们经常为之鼓掌。他们因这些过高的标准而受到赞赏。仿佛它是一种荣誉勋章。我会比任何人都努力工作，因为我永远无法向自己证明我足够优秀。在完美主义的背后，它关乎的不是卓越，而往往是恐惧。它关于那种挥之不去的、持续的担忧，担心自己会做得不够好，担心如果不够完美，自己就不够好。你毫无价值。你的生活缺乏意义。人们永远不会爱你。这很快就会变得在心理上相当沉重。我们许多人都是带着
that kind of pressure, especially in our 20s and 30s, when everything feels like it's supposed to be figured out ahead of schedule. A 2022 study of young people aged 16 to 25 actually found that 85% of participants identified as having perfectionist traits, particularly around academic achievement. But it can be so many things. It can be obsessing over the right career, how your body looks, how your relationship looks, your timeline. Basically, we've learned to equate a, with external appearances and external value and therefore self-worth. But the reality is perfectionism doesn't drive success as much as it actually drives exhaustion. It is not the superpower that we all believe it is.
这种压力生活的，尤其是在我们二十多岁和三十多岁的时候，当时一切都感觉应该在预定时间之前弄明白。2022年对16至25岁年轻人的研究实际上发现，85%的参与者认为自己具有完美主义特质，尤其是在学业成就方面。但这可以是很多事情。它可以是对合适职业、身材外貌、恋爱关系、人生时间表的着迷。基本上，我们已经学会将外表和外部价值与自我价值划等号。但现实是，完美主义并没有推动成功，反而实际上推动了精疲力竭。它并不是我们所有人所相信的超能力。
Before we go further, we actually need to talk about the main types of perfectionism. There is not just one. It is a lot more complex than just wanting things to be good. there are actually three main strains or versions of this trait. The first one is self-orientated perfectionism. This is when you set your own impossible standards. And it's about an internal drive to prove to yourself that, you know, you can control your life, that you have value, that you can do good things.
在我们深入探讨之前，我们实际上需要讨论主要类型的完美主义。它不只一种。它要比仅仅想要把事情做好复杂得多，实际上有这种特质的三种主要表现形式或版本。第一种是自我导向型完美主义。这是当你设定自己不可能达到的标准时。这关乎一种内在驱动力，向自己证明你知道你可以掌控自己的生活，你是有价值的，你可以做好事。
You're the one telling yourself that you can't make mistakes. you're the one who has this relentless internal critic that is never satisfied no matter how well you do. Then there is the other oriented perfectionist. This one's a little bit different. It's when you hold the people around you to the same impossible standards you hold yourself to. Maybe this shows up in your relationships, friendships, friendships at work. You want the world to be perfect. You want people to push themselves the way you push yourself.
你是那个告诉自己不能犯错的人。你就是那个拥有这种无情、无论你做得多好也永远不会满足的内心批判者的人。然后是他人导向型完美主义。这个有点不同。这是当你用要求自己的那些不可能达到的标准来要求周围的人时。也许这会表现在你的恋爱关系、友情、职场友情中。你希望世界是完美的。你希望人们像你鞭策自己一样鞭策他们自己。
You expect others to meet your level of precision, care, and that can cause a lot of tension and disappointment when they don't. It also drives you to try and lead by example. So older siblings, sports captains, bosses, even parents get this feeling a lot. And finally, we have socially prescribed perfectionism. This is the one that's become increasingly, massive in recent years. It is the feeling that everyone else is perfect. Everyone else expects you to be perfect. It's the feeling that you're constantly being watched, judged, evaluated,
你期望别人达到你那样的精确度和关怀度，而当他们做不到时，这会引起很多紧张和失望。这也驱使你试图以身作则。所以年长的兄弟姐妹、运动队长、老板，甚至父母经常会有这种感觉。最后，我们有社会规定型完美主义。这是近年来变得越来越巨大的那一种。这是一种感觉，好像其他人都是完美的。其他所有人都期望你是完美的。这是一种感觉，好像你一直在被注视、被评判、被评估，
and so you have to keep up. You have to look the part. Socially prescribed perfectionism is deeply tied to our current culture. Of course, social media, comparison, our online culture, this constant subtle pressure to perform, this sense. of being visible, and that is why this form of perfectionism has grown so significantly over time. There was a 2019 review published in the journal Psychological Bulletin, which looked at changes in levels of perfectionism between 1989 and 2016 in the US, in the UK, and in Canada, using college students as the participant group. What they found was that, yes, all types of perfectionism rose over time.
因此你必须跟上步伐。你必须看起来像那么回事。社会规定型完美主义与我们当前的文化息息相关。当然，社交媒体、攀比、我们的网络文化，这种持续而微妙的表演压力，这种被看见的感觉，这就是为什么这种形式的完美主义随着时间的推移增长如此显著。2019年发表在《心理学公报》杂志上的一篇综述探讨了美国、英国和加拿大在1989年至2016年间完美主义水平的变化，以大学生群体作为参与者。他们发现的是，是的，所有类型的完美主义都在随着时间推移而上升。
Socially prescribed perfectionism, though, has risen so significantly, such that it is the most common form of perfectionism that we currently see. And the researchers noted this as a concern because what this indicates is that young people, people in their teens, in their 20s are becoming inquiries. increasingly more sensitive to external pressures and they are finding it more difficult than previous generations to cope and to re-center themselves. Here is the final twist of the knife here. Socially prescribed perfectionism is actually the most debilitating of all three types
然而，社会规定型完美主义上升得如此显著，以至于它成了我们目前看到的最常见的完美主义形式。研究人员对此表示担忧，因为这表明年轻人，十几岁、二十多岁的年轻人，变得对外部压力越来越敏感，而且他们比前几代人发现更难以应对并重新调整自己。这里是最后一记重拳。社会规定型完美主义实际上是所有这三种类型的完美主义中最具破坏性的，
of perfectionism and wider research consistently connects it to pretty major health concerns, anxiety, depression, even eating disorders, of course, you know, if we're constantly measuring our worth through others, through people's expectations, through these metrics of success, unless you are the very best in every domain and dimension of life, you are falling short. So you may as well be the worst. Perfectionism is so harmful in that way because it deeply embodies black and white thinking. Either I'm number one or I'm nothing. Either I get everything right or I should give up. This raises the stakes so high that we actually can't operate under these conditions. And so
更广泛的研究一致将其与相当重大的健康问题联系起来，如焦虑、抑郁，甚至饮食失调，当然，你知道，如果我们不断地通过他人、通过人们的期望、通过这些成功的指标来衡量我们的价值，除非你在生活中的每一个领域和维度都是最好的，否则你就是在退步。所以你干脆当最差的算了。完美主义在这一点上非常有害，因为它深深体现了非黑即白的思维。要么我是第一，要么我什么都不是。要么我把所有事情都做对，要么我就应该放弃。这把赌注抬得如此之高，以至于我们在这种情况下根本无法运作。因此
you procrastinate, you avoid starting, you work yourself to the point of no return, you become more obsessive about what other people think until you can't achieve anything. Now here's where perfectionism gets really sneaky because in our culture, perfectionism is often disguised as discipline. And so even when it feels bad, it looks good. And we convince ourselves that it should feel good as well. We are hardworking. We are committed. We are detail-orientated. These things are all admirable. Except actually, a lot of us, a lot of people who are born and raised perfectionists are starting to realize that like the dream we are sold by this trait is a complete lie. And actually we will never ever get to a point where we are actually satisfied with what we have.
你会拖延，你会避免开始，你会工作到无法回头的地步，你会对别人的看法变得更加着迷，直到你什么也做不成。现在，这就是完美主义变得非常狡猾的地方，因为在我们的文化中，完美主义往往伪装成纪律。因此，即使感觉不好，它看起来也很好。我们说服自己，它应该也感觉很好。我们很努力。我们很执着。我们注重细节。这些事情都是令人钦佩的。除了实际上，我们中的许多人，许多生来就是完美主义者的人开始意识到，这种特质向我们兜售的梦想完全是个谎言。事实上，我们永远、永远不会达到对我们所拥有的东西真正感到满意的地步。
It just keeps us in the cycle. And now discipline, being hardworking, those are great traits. So how do we tell the difference between this insatiable need to be the best and to never make mistakes? and this desire to truly work hard for something and to really be passionate. We tell the difference through motivation. What is our motivation? Discipline is motivated by growth. We want to do well because we care about whatever it is we're doing and we like the challenge.
它只是把我们困在循环中。现在，纪律性、勤奋，这些都是很好的特质。那么我们如何区分这种永无止境的渴望——想要成为最好、永不犯错的渴望——与真正为某事努力工作、真正充满激情的愿望呢？我们通过动机来区分。我们的动机是什么？纪律是由成长驱动的。我们想要做好，是因为我们在乎我们正在做的任何事情，并且我们喜欢这种挑战。
Whether we fail or not, we obviously want to succeed, but the process is something that we are invigorated by, excited by enjoying. Perfectionism is motivated by feeling. We feel as though we have to do this. We have to do well. We have to push ourselves. Otherwise, we are worthless. No one wakes up one day and just decides they're going to start being terrified of mistakes. Like most of our deep-rooted psychological patterns, perfectionism begins early.
无论我们失败与否，我们显然都想成功，但这个过程是我们感到精神焕发、兴奋并享受其中的过程。完美主义是由感觉驱动的。我们觉得我们不得不这么做。我们必须做好。我们必须鞭策自己。否则，我们就是一文不值的。没有人会在某一天醒来，然后就决定开始害怕犯错。就像我们大多数根深蒂固的心理模式一样，完美主义始于早期。
It begins when we feel we needed to earn love, whether that was from family, from friends, from mentors, from who, whatever it was. A lot of us grow up learning, consciously or unconsciously, love or approval is earned. Maybe you earn it through good grades, good behavior, achievements, being the easy child over time that creates this core belief. Love is conditional. You only deserve to enjoy life and you only deserve to enjoy love or to have it when you perform when you get it right. So psychologists call this conditional regard. It is one of the
它始于我们觉得我们需要赢得爱的时候，无论是来自家庭、朋友、导师，还是来自任何人、任何事物。我们许多人在成长过程中，有意识或无意识地了解到，爱或认可都是赢得的。也许你是通过好成绩、好表现、成就、做个听话的孩子来赢得它的，随着时间的推移，这创造了一个核心信念。爱是有条件的。你只配享受生活，你只有在表现良好、做对事情时才配享受爱或拥有爱。心理学家称之为条件性关注。它是以后生活中
strongest predictors of perfectionist tendencies later in life. Research published in the Journal of Personality found that when parents express affection or approval only when their children meet expectations and when they withdraw it when they fail, those children are more likely to internalize a sense of conditional worth. They grow up feeling that that mistake equals deep psychological rejection and that to be loved, they have to constantly strive and achieve. Another study published in, I think it was 2005, found that adolescents who were exposed to this kind of unconditional, sorry, conditional parenting, conditional love showed high levels
完美主义倾向的最强预测指标之一。发表在《人格杂志》上的一项研究发现，当父母只有在孩子达到期望时才表达喜爱或认可，而在孩子失败时则收回这些时，这些孩子更有可能内化一种条件性价值感。他们在成长过程中会觉得，犯错等同于深深的心理拒绝，为了被爱，他们必须不断奋斗和取得成就。另一项发表在——我想是2005年的——研究发现，接触这种无条件（抱歉，是有条件）育儿、有条件爱的青少年表现出高度的
of self-critical perfectionism and internalized pressure, even years down the line. this part of them became fundamental to how they saw themselves and how they operated and how they showed up years and years into the future. Another element of this is also the role of insecurity and self-worth. It's not just about love, it's about how you see yourself as valuable. If at your core you don't feel inherently worthy or good or seen, if you've internalized the belief that I'm only good when I achieve or I have output, perfectionism is a way to compensate for what you feel like you're lacking.
自我批判的完美主义和内化压力，甚至在多年之后也是如此。他们身上的这一部分成为了他们看待自己、如何运作以及未来多年如何表现的基础。这其中的另一个要素也是不安全感和自我价值的作用。这不仅关乎爱，还关乎你如何看待自己的价值。如果你的核心感受不到自己本质上有价值、优秀或被看见，如果你内化了“我只有在取得成就或有产出时才优秀”的信念，完美主义就是一种补偿你觉得自己所缺之物的方式。
I relate to this deeply. I didn't fit in growing up. I didn't really have good friends. I wasn't hot. I wasn't popular. I really wasn't anything special that I could work hard and I could get good grades. And so that pursuit, this, I knew this about myself. I knew I could push myself.
我对这一点感同身受。我成长过程中很不合群。我没有真正的好朋友。我不火。我不受欢迎。我真的没有什么特别之处，但我可以努力工作，我可以取得好成绩。所以那种追求，这个，我很清楚这一点。我知道我可以鞭策自己。
That became my identity. And it became a way to feel good about myself in an environment where I previously didn't and where I didn't have a role and where I didn't belong. And it was deeply protective of my ego. This is something that humanistic psychologists like Carl Rogers have written about for decades. When somebody's self-worth is based on external things, the authentic self-self gets replaced with this ideal self. That's the version of us that we're always striving, chasing, wanting to be, but we never quite feel like we will get there. It's a big fat lie, right?
这成了我的身份。这成了一种在以前不属于我的环境中、在没有角色和归属感的地方让自己感觉良好的方式。这极大地保护了我的自我。这是像卡尔·罗杰斯这样的人本主义心理学家几十年来一直在撰写的内容。当某人的自我价值建立在外部事物上时，真实的自我就会被这个理想的自我所取代。那是我们一直在努力奋斗、追逐、想要成为的版本，但我们从来没有完全觉得我们会到达那里。这是一个弥天大谎，对吧？
We have this idea that if we just extend, push, work, do more, we will get to a place of satisfaction. That is a lie. It is a mental Ponzi scheme that tells you to invest more, that tells you just to get to the next target, and you'll finally feel good, but never rewards you. The final reason we develop perfectionism is actually really about control. I don't feel like a lot of people talk about it from this angle, but we're going to consider this deeply in just a second after this short break. Stay with us. 2%.
我们有一种想法，如果我们只是扩展、推挤、工作、做更多的事情，我们就会到达一个满足的地方。那是谎言。这是一个精神庞氏骗局，告诉你投入更多，告诉你只要达到下一个目标，你就会最终感觉良好，但它从不奖励你。我们发展出完美主义的最后一个原因实际上是关于控制。我觉得没有多少人从这个角度谈论过它，但在短暂的休息之后，我们将在短短一秒钟内深入思考这一点。请继续收听。《2%》。
That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world,
这就是在也有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中。我剖析了在我们这个奇特的现代世界中培养心理坚韧、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以看穿主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题，
are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是TWO%。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMAs上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小基有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代可卡因的节目。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备在白天谈论可卡因，但为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集。所以我开始看到这其中有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade.
谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年的
of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
我自己对心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在追逐它。
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid.
我们不知道什么时候做得够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这里做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你害怕。
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
因为那是两个不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难抉择》中，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标进行真实的对话。
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed, revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了她故事中显而易见的不一致之处。这开始了长达数年的法院诉讼来证明真相。埃伦斯女士，这份特定的检测报告你伪造了两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次检测报告。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格、一个女同性恋者、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man. should live by.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在新一季的《闺蜜》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《闺蜜》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Perfectionism can sometimes develop as a way not just to feel love, not just to feel worthy, but to manage our anxiety or the unpredictability of. life because it gives this mental impression that if we just work hard enough, if we just check over things a million times, if we rehearse everything, have a million to-do lists, we can control whatever life throws at us. Perfectionism is actually really deeply aligned with an intolerance for uncertainty. We've spoken about this before, but our intolerance for uncertainty
相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。完美主义有时会发展成为一种方式，不仅是为了感受爱，不仅是为了感受自己的价值，而是为了管理我们的焦虑或生活的不确定性，因为它给人一种心理印记：如果我们只是足够努力地工作，如果我们只是把事情检查一百万遍，如果我们排练一切，有一百万个待办事项清单，我们就能掌控生活抛给我们的任何东西。完美主义实际上与对不确定性的不容忍有着深刻的一致性。我们以前谈过这个，但我们对不确定性的不容忍
is this extra feeling of distress that we face when we understand that something is unpredictable or unknown. Some of us are more intolerant than others. Some of us face increasing or more anxiety compared to others. If you've learnt that unpredictable situations often lead to pain like conflict, rejection, criticism that you previously were not able to cope with or didn't feel supported through or were really overwhelmed by, you might cope. by trying to eliminate uncertainty altogether through the process of perfectionist control. It's a lie.
是我们面临的额外痛苦感，当我们明白某事是不可预测的或未知的时候。我们中的有些人比其他人更不能容忍。与其他人相比，我们中的有些人面临着不断增加的或更多的焦虑。如果你了解到不可预测的情况通常会导致痛苦，比如冲突、拒绝、批评，而你以前无法应对，或者觉得没有得到支持，或者真的被压得喘不过气来，你可能会通过试图消除不确定性来应对。通过完美主义控制的过程。这是个谎言。
Again, this whole feeling is just like trying to sell you. It's trying to sell you this idealistic view of the world that the people who work hard are the ones who get love and the ones who get achievement and the ones who can control the world. It's trying to basically convince us that there is something within us that can determine all of these outcomes or all of these truths that we want to know about ourselves. We want to know that we have value. We want to know that we're loved.
再次强调，整个感觉就像是在向你推销。它试图向你推销这样一种世界观：努力工作的人是那些得到爱、得到成就、能够控制世界的人。它基本上试图说服我们，我们内心有什么东西可以决定所有这些结果，或者我们想要了解的关于我们自己的所有真相。我们想知道我们有价值。我们想知道我们被爱。
We want to know that we're going to be okay. And in our attempts to gain certainty on those things, perfectionism becomes the way through which we think we enact it and through which we gain it. All of this, it's just a coping mechanism. One that looks bloody fantastic from the outside. I'm sure if you're listening to this episode, you've got great grades in school. I'm sure you had a job growing up. You had hobbies, extracurriculars, you made your parents proud, you had high standards,
我们想知道我们会没事的。在我们试图获得关于这些事情的确定性的过程中，完美主义成了我们认为我们实施它并获得它的途径。所有这一切，都只是一种应对机制。一种从外部看起来血淋淋地美妙的机制。我相信如果你在听这一期节目，你在学校里成绩优异。我相信你长大后有一份工作。你有爱好、课外活动，你让你的父母感到骄傲，你有着高标准，
you went to a good school, you always had some kind of side hustle. But can I ask you a question right now? Are you actually happy? Genuinely, if I took all of that away, would you know what you actually like doing? Would you know who you actually are? Would you be doing half of what you're doing now with a lot of you're doing? without external approval. How many things do you do not because you have ever enjoyed them,
你上了一所好学府，你总是有某种副业。但我现在能问你一个问题吗？你真的快乐吗？说实话，如果我把这一切都拿走，你知道你真正喜欢做什么吗？你知道你究竟是谁吗？如果没有外部认可，你在做的事情里有一半是你现在会做的吗？你有多少事情不是因为你曾经喜欢它们，
but because you think that you have to? That is the paradox of perfectionism. Often it begins as a way to feel in control, to feel loved and worthy, and it ends up controlling you with golden handcuffs. It is your best friend because you know it gives you outcomes, it gives you output, you know you can rely on it, it gets stuff done. It's also your worst enemy. So how do we loosen the grip of perfectionism
而是因为你认为你必须这样做？这就是完美主义的悖论。通常它开始时是一种掌控感、被爱和有价值感的方式，而最终它用金手铐控制了你。它是你最好的朋友，因为你知道它给你带来结果，它给你带来产出，你知道你可以依靠它，它能把事情做好。它也是你最大的敌人。那么当完美主义已经融入我们体内如此之久、几乎感觉像是第二层皮肤时，我们该如何放松对它的紧握呢？首先，我希望你想象你真正、真正向往的生活。生动地想象它，你的房子、你的日常生活、你穿的衣服、你的朋友、你晚饭吃什么、你的房子长什么样。现在认真问自己，做一个完美主义者
when it has been a part of us for so long that it almost feels like a second skin? Firstly, I want you imagine the life you really, really want. Vividly imagine it, your house, your day-to-day life, what you're wearing, who your friends are, what you have for dinner, what your house looks like. Now seriously ask yourself, will being a perfectionist? allow me to be that person and even if it does will it allow me to enjoy even my dream life? Is there a future where my perfectionism will actually let me be satisfied? The best way I found to start tackling my perfectionism in the now is to use future mindedness or what psychology calls prospection to kind of observe how perfection
能让我成为那样的人吗？即使能，它能让我连自己的梦想生活也一起享受吗？有没有这样一个未来，我的完美主义真的能让我感到满足？我发现开始解决眼下完美主义的最好方法是使用面向未来的心态，或者心理学上所说的预期，来观察完美主义将如何继续在未来伤害我。我真的发现阻止自己这样做的唯一方法，就是专注于我知道只会不断增加的所有负面影响。就像，完美主义就像病毒的细胞计数。就像如果我不挑战它，它将继续渗透到我生活中的方方面面。如果我不挑战这种“我需要成为最好、这必须是完美”的想法。那将慢慢决定我对生活和自我的整体看法。甚至就像把自己投影到临终的病榻上，我知道这感觉有点病态，但它给了我一些视角。这种心态真的能帮到我吗？继续专注于这些实际上并不重要的东西，我会失去什么？
perfectionism will continue to hurt me into the future. I really find that the only way I can stop myself from doing it is to focus on all the downsides that I know will only increase. Like, perfectionism is like the cell count of a virus. Like it will continue to infiltrate everything in my life if I don't challenge it. If I don't challenge this thought that I need to be the best, this needs to be perfect. That will slowly determine my entire outlook on life and how I see myself. Even like projecting myself onto my deathbed, I know it feels morbid, gives me some perspective. Is this mindset actually going to help me? What am I going to lose out on by continuing to focus on these things that don't actually matter?
另一个帮到我的事情是，最重要的是，不时地过一个没有工作、没有项目、没有外表、没有网络的一天。我试着每两周做一次。你知道，我从事的行业让我很容易不断地去量化我的工作有多好，与其他人相比我做得有多好，以及我的立场在哪里。你知道，播客简直有一个每日更新的排名。作为一个完美主义者，那是地狱。那是噩梦般的燃料。意识到数字，所有那些东西其实并没有量化真实的生活，也没有真正决定我的感觉，这是很有帮助的。并且拥有这样一些日子，我可以断开与所有这些的连接，去做我的人类大脑和灵魂最渴望的事情，比如远足、游泳、和朋友吃饭、闲逛，
Another thing that has helped me is more than anything else, having a work-free, project-free, appearance-free, online-free day every day. now and again. I try and do it once a fortnight. You know, I work in an industry that makes it so easy to constantly be quantifying how good my work is and how well I'm doing in comparison to others and where I stand. You know, podcasts literally have a daily ranking that is updated. Like, as a perfectionist, that is hell. That is nightmare fuel. Realizing that numbers, all those things like don't actually quantify real life and don't actually determine how I feel is helpful. And having days where I can just disconnect from all of that and do things my human brain and soul wants most of all like hiking, swimming, eating with friends, dilly dallying,
这让我感觉自己不那么像一台机器，而更像是一个来这里感受和体验、而不是为了追求结果的人。无论如何，这些结果随着时间推移都会消逝。在我死后不久，这些就不会持续太久了。真的，变得有点病态确实对我有帮助。这些休息日也提醒我，工作不是一种爱好。不断地在自己身上、在项目上、在工作上努力，并不是打发我所有时间的足够好的方式。当然，我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我享受它。我有一种想要做得更多的强烈感觉。它真的给了我我所付出的吗？
like that makes me feel less like a machine and more like somebody who is here to feel and experience rather than to get results. That will fade over time anyways. That will not last much longer past the time I'm dead. Like, it really does help me to get morbid. It also helps remind me these days off that working isn't a hobby. Constantly working on myself, on a project, on my job, isn't a good enough way to spend all my time. Sure, I like it. I like it. I enjoy it. I feel a deep sense of like intensity to do it more. Is it actually giving me what I'm giving it?
不。你知道，不，它不是，工作不是一种爱好。我需要更多的东西。如果我真的想耍点小聪明，老实说，我不知道这是否是治疗师会推荐的做法，听听就好，但我尽量在休息日做到放松得最好。我尽量在腾出时间时表现得尽可能完美。
No. You know, no, it's not work is not a hobby. I need something more. If I really want to be sneaky and to be honest, I don't know if this is something a therapist would recommend or not, take it with a grain of salt, but I try on my days off to be the best at relaxing. I try to be as perfect as possible at taking time off.
我试着用最好的方式做到最好，成为享受生活的第一名。不是，你知道，在不根据别人来给自己打分方面拿第一，这很讽刺。但我觉得，如果我要这样做，如果我要休息，如果我要从完美主义中歇口气，我最好把它做得非常、非常出色。你知道吗？它可能仍然保持着潜意识里的冲动。但我喜欢说，这是在物尽其用，用它来真正地强迫
I try to do it in the best possible way to be number one at enjoying life. Not, you know, number one at not grading myself based on others, which is ironic. But I'm like, if I'm going to do this, if I'm going to take time off, if I'm going to take a break from my perfectionism, I better do it really, really well. And you know what? It probably still keeps the underlying impulse alive. But I like to say it is using it for good and using it to really like force. myself to not half-ass my time off. A tip I also picked up from the book, The Perfectionist
自己不要敷衍了事地对待休息时间。我也从《完美主义者的失控指南》一书中挑选了一个小建议，老实说，如果你对我说的话有任何共鸣，去买一本那本书来看看吧，那就是把“完美”的概念换成“更好”，遵循1%法则，而不是一下子变得100%更好，一次好1%。不要忽视这个法则。把它应用到你的生活中。当你注意到自己在某件以前做过的事情上有了轻微的进步时，把它应用到你的成功中。注意到它，庆祝它。当你努力工作时，休息一下。让事情顺其自然，而不是催促它们。以1%的水平去做，因为你不会精疲力竭。你将有时间留给自己。你将能够享受这个过程，并且你能够让宇宙发挥作用。让生活为你烹饪出美好的事物。让事情顺其自然地
Guy to Losing Control, which honestly, if you're resonating with anything I'm saying, go and pick up a copy of that book, was also to swap the idea of perfect to better and to follow the 1% rule, not 100% better all at once, 1% better at a time. And don't ignore that rule. Apply it to your life. Apply it to your wins when you notice you've been. proved slightly on something you did before. Notice it, celebrate it. When you've worked hard, take a break. Let things take their time rather than rushing them. Do it at the 1% level because you won't burn out. You will have time for yourself. You'll be able to enjoy the process and you will be able to like let the universe cook. Let life cook you up something great. Let things take
花它们需要的时间去成熟、变得更好并看到进步。最后，用你的价值观而不是别人的标准重新定义成功。完美主义让你追逐外部指标、成绩、数字、赞美、结果、奖牌，我不知道还有什么，比如所有那些想把进步塞进数字或等级制度的盒子里面的东西。但这些等级制度、那些数字位置、那些可量化的指标是无止境的，它们永远不会带来平静。所以相反，问问你自己，什么对我来说比什么都重要？现在再次提出这个问题，但做一点微小的调整，如果没有人看着，什么对我来说最重要？
the time they need to mature and to get better and to see progress. Finally, redefine success using your values rather than somebody else's standards. Perfectionism makes you chase external metrics, grades, numbers, praise, outcomes, medals, I don't know what else, like all those kinds of things that want to put progress into a box that is numerical or hierarchical. but those hierarchies, those number places, those quantifiable metrics are endless and they never lead to peace. So instead, ask yourself, what matters most to me more than anything? Now ask the question again, but with a slightly different tweak, what would matter most to me
我该如何追求更多那样的事情？另一个问题是，我实际上每天都想有什么样的感觉？如果我花更少的时间去追求完美，这种感觉在哪些方面已经对我唾手可得了？最后，完美主义在追求梦想生活的过程中是帮了我还是害了我？当你把你的努力与价值观而不是与完美、与这种拐杖对齐时，焦点就会从“我做这件事完美无瑕吗”转变为“我做这件事有意义吗？我做这件事的方式是否符合我真正渴望的？”我认为这是一种更温和、更可持续的奋斗形式。
if no one was watching? How do I chase more of that? Another question is, how do I actually want to feel every day? And in what ways would that feeling already be available to me if I spent less time trying to be perfect? And finally, does perfectionism help me or harm me in my pursuit of my dream life? When you align your efforts with values instead of with perfection, with this crutch, the focus shifts from, did I do this flawlessly to did I do this in a meaningful way? Did I do this in a way that was aligned with what I actually desire? And I think that's a much kinder, more sustainable form of striving.
归根结底，这就是我今天想结束这期小额外节目的地方，重构完美主义并不是要降低你的标准。这不是关于放弃。你已经一次又一次地向自己证明了。如果你想把自己累死，你可以做到。毫无疑问。这不是你做不到的问题，而是你应不应该做的问题。
Ultimately, and this is where I really want to finish today's little bonus episode, reframing perfectionism isn't about lowering your standards. It's not about quitting. You have proven to yourself time and time again. If you wanted to work yourself to the bone, you can do it. There's no doubt about that. It's not that you can't do it. It's whether you should.
最后，这也是我今天这期加更节目真正想总结的，重新定义完美主义并不是降低你的标准，也不是要你放弃。你已经一次又一次地向自己证明了，如果你想拼命工作，你是做得到的。毫无疑问，你不是做不到，而是你该不该这么做。
It's whether this is actually making you happy. And it's learning to detach from how you think people will see you when you're the one who has to feel your life. How people see your life matters so much less than what it's going to feel for you to be in it. And it's learning to really include things like joy, curiosity, rest, connection in your definition of success. because they are some of the best things about life and you will miss out on them if you are in this constant relentless pursuit of goals that are sometimes completely arbitrary. You know, again, I just want to say it more time, I know you can work hard. Everybody around you knows you can work hard.
关键在于这是否真的能让你快乐。我们要学会摆脱这种想法：当你要亲自去感受自己的人生时，别人会如何看待你。别人怎么看你的人生，远不如你亲自去经历它时的感受来得重要。我们要学会把快乐、好奇心、休息和人际连接真正融入对成功的定义中，因为这些才是生活中最美好的事物。如果你一直在无休止地追逐那些有时完全毫无意义的目标，你就会错过这些美好。你知道的，我只想再说一次，我知道你能吃苦。你身边的每个人都知道你能吃苦。
You know it as well. But is it going to make you happy? Is this coping mechanism actually helping your life get better? Or is it leading you to chase things that aren't actually fulfilling? And that you know deep down leave you feeling quite empty. So thank you for listening to My Musings on Perfectionism. I hope it's just given you something to think about. If you have made it this far, I want you to leave a little book emoji down below
你自己也很清楚。但这真的能让你快乐吗？这种应对机制真的能让你的生活变得更好吗？还是说它正引导你去追逐那些其实并不能带来真正的满足感、而且你内心深处知道只会让你感到无比空虚的东西？感谢收听我的“完美主义随想录”。希望这能给你带来一些启发。如果你听到了这里，我希望你在下方留下一个小小的书本表情符号。
I feel like that ties in with how perfectionism really shows up in academia and in our studies and in work. Thank you for being a loyal listener. Thank you for letting me have your attention for these 26 minutes. I really appreciate it. Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast and that you are following along or subscribed. Whatever you are listening to this episode, I would also really appreciate if you could give us a five-star review, especially if you are listening on Apple. Reviews really help the show grow and reach new people,
我觉得这与完美主义在学术界、我们的学业和工作中的表现方式息息相关。感谢你一直以来的忠实聆听。感谢你在这26分钟里给予我你的关注，我真的非常感激。同时也请确保在Instagram上关注我们的心理学播客账号，并且订阅或关注我们。无论你在哪里收听这个节目，如果你能给我们一个五星好评，尤其是如果你在Apple上收听的话，我也会非常感激。评论真的能帮助节目成长并接触到更多新听众，
which is really important to me. I also want to thank our researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions to this episode. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk very, very soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J.
这对我来说真的非常重要。我还要感谢我们的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。1979年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是亚历克斯·英格利希。每一期节目中，我们都会邀请你来到这里，剖析发生的过往，并和我们的朋友、喜剧同行以及最喜爱的作家一起，试着去理解我们是如何挺过那段时光的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代那样。那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的一年了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host's Kier Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首过往》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你们喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯（Kier Games）为你带来的《艰难学习》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全、但在这里你可以和一个真正懂得怎么做的持证专业人士一起进行的坦诚对话。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct?
有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你是不容好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测结果两次，对吧？
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
我伪造了一次检测。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人——格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能以及在这个奇特现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。那是“TWO%”，在iHeartRadio App上架。
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts，或在你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子交往过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。